the number of smartphone users global to
set to reach 2.5 billion by 2019 around
a third of the world's population will
own one smartphones touch every element
of our lives but did you know that they
also connect nearly every element on the
planet in fact of the 118 elements on
the periodic table 75 can be found
inside a smartphone these raw materials
are extracted from the ground and
shipped to refineries and factories in a
truly global supply chain silicon one of
the most common elements in the Earth's
crust is used to make the billions of
transistors in the chips that power your
phone gold is used for electrical wiring
about naught point naught 3 grams of it
in each iPhone indium another metal is
used to make touchscreens
but when it comes to batteries lithium
is one really key component and this
element is only mined in a handful of
countries until recently Chile used to
produce the most lithium but now
Australia has the biggest market share
the Democratic Republic of Congo a
dangerously unstable country with a poor
human rights record produces more than
half the world's cobalt another crucial
element in smartphone batteries
smartphone makers are under pressure to
ensure their cobalt is responsibly
sourced about 80% of the cobalt used in
batteries is refined in China many
so-called rare earth elements are also
used in smartphones in the screen for
speaker and the motor that makes your
phone vibrate about 85 percent of rare
earth elements are produced in China
despite their name rare earth elements
are not particularly rare but they are
hard to extract without producing toxic
and radioactive byproducts many of the
elements used in smartphones are finite
resources and have no functional
substitutes rather than digging in the
ground for the elements needed for new
handsets it makes sense to extract them
from old phones but only about 10% of
handsets are recycled now so recycle
your phone if you get a new one this
year why it is you might say Elementary
you